With Season 5B of Lucifer here, it's time
to hunt through all the new episodes for those
delicious easter eggs and hilarious details
the crew snuck in for all us Lucifans!
"So many easter eggs from our previous adventures."
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and in
this video I'm revealing the top 50 heavenly
details you missed in Part 2 of Lucifer Season
5!
Spoilers ahead, of course, so take care.
Lucifer proves he's a devil of his word at
the start of episode 9.
See this guy dancing at Lux as Luci plays
"Footloose" on the piano?
Well, he's the security guard that Luci made
a devilish deal with in the midseason finale:
"I want to be a dancer."
"Well, you're in luck, Baryshnikov.
I'll hire you and make your Footloose dreams
come true.
What do you say?
Deal?"
Given Dan's previous relationship with the
Goddess, meeting her husband was always going
to be super-awkward.
So, I bet he was glad to see Lucifer distract
God with some snacks:
"Dad, why don't I show you the vending machines?
Have you tried Cool Ranch Puffs?"
And as we know from Season 1, those particular
snacks are Luci's favourites:
"Cool ranch puff?
It's funny, isn't it?
You'd think the king of hellfire would be
more of a flaming hot guy, but..."
I love the symmetry of these shots of Lucifer
and God when they end up in a therapy session
at Dr Linda's as it shows that father and
son have more in common than they might think,
pointing to how Lucifer will become God in
the season finale.
And if you look carefully, you can see a parenting
book called How To Raise Successful People
on Linda's desk, which she's doubtless reading
for her son Charlie,
but it also feels fitting for the high-powered
people currently occupying her couch.
The musical episode is an absolute blast,
with lively performances, Busby Berkeley-style
choreography, a cameo from singer-songwriter
Debbie Gibson;
and yes, even God starts bopping along.
On top of that, we also get plenty of signs
of what's to come by the end of the season:
Dan's concerns over having slept with God's
wife,
"Which means I'm definitely going to Hell"
and the song he sings foreshadow Amenadiel's
discovery that his friend isn't in Heaven.
Lucifer shutting down a flame with his hand
and his clothes burning up while he remains
unscathed,
"You okay?"
"Yes.
Of course I am."
foreshadow his flaming fate in Heaven and
signal that ultimately he'll emerge unharmed.
And then there are the literal signs we see
Chloe and Lucifer standing by at the school
as she tells him she has faith in him and
that she's sure he'll work things out with
his dad.
'Flying to the top in just one day' and 'Another
victory on its way', say the signs, pointing
to Chloe and Luci's heavenly ascent in the
finale and Team Lucifer's triumph over his
villainous twin.
At the gym of self-styled "fitness guru to
the stars", Kristoff, there's a bunch of posters
of well-known clients he's worked with, all
of whom have been part of Chloe and Luci's
cases at some point.
There's the cast of ¡Lieutenant Diablo!,
the network TV show that's an hilariously
OTT version of Lucifer.
And there's Holla Bae, a murdered DJ whose
body was taken over by a demon in the season
4 finale.
Then there's the Blazing Banshees, a roller
derby team involved in a murder-kidnap case,
and their rivals the Derby Divas.
The Bobby Lowe Show features a comedian who
stole jokes from another comic that ended
up being murdered before he could reveal the
truth.
Axara is the pop sensation whose life was
threatened in the episode Let Pinhead Sing!
As for Top Meet, that's an exclusive celebrity
dating app whose designer was murdered.
And apparently, Kristoff has featured on "The
Cabin", a hit reality TV programme Ella loves
where a contestant was killed in Season 4.
Given so many of the clients in the posters
are now dead, it certainly brings new meaning
to the sign "Bodies by Kristoff".
When Lucifer and Chloe go to interview a murder
suspect who owns an adventure park, he gets
the wrong end of the stick and tries to flee
the scene in one of his go-karts:
"Thought you were arresting me for the ZX3!
It's an illegal..."
"...chemical used in street racing.
Surprisingly useful in other ways.
We're familiar."
This is a throwback to Season 2 where Luci
went to hell and back to get the formula for
the antidote to save Chloe after she was poisoned.
And ZX3 was the final ingredient needed to
create that antidote.
"A chemical called ZX3.
Super rare, super illegal."
In a somewhat ironic twist, the same chemical
that was used to save a life back then winds
up ending one this season.
"We found traces of ZX3 in the fuel that burned
down the Kingdom."
Most crucially though, the fact this super-rare
chemical crops up again at the start of Season
5B foreshadows how Chloe will need saving
from death once more in the season finale.
In an effort to work on his relationship with
his father, Lucifer takes him to the precinct,
but God's reaction when he discovers Luci
doesn't have a throne, office, or even a desk
is priceless, and Dennis Haysbert delivers
the line perfectly:
"He has a desk.
Maybe if you work hard enough, you might one
day rise to this man's level."
This comment must really sting as Lucifer's
not only being compared unfavourably to Detective
Douche, but it'll probably also remind him
of how Chloe turned him down in Season 2 when
he requested a desk next to hers.
"I should get my own desk."
"Not happening."
"Right next to yours would probably be best."
"Definitely not happening."
Of course, their relationship was at a very
different stage to that by Season 5A and Lucifer
was happy to see Chloe make herself at home
at his desk in Lux:
"This desk has never looked so good."
When Team Lucifer try stalling their face-off
with Michael to give Maze time to arrive,
they break into song to pretend that God's
back.
But this isn't the first time that MC Hammer's
U Can't Touch has cropped up on the show.
In Season 4, during their investigation into
the death of a realtor, Ella also broke out
the 90s track.
"Stop!
Hammer time!"
In the midst of his insane adventures in episode
12, Dan tells Ella he needs some advice to
get inside the criminal mind:
"I actually do know how to fake the perfect
murder.
Because...
I've been working on it for my novel.
So, it's about a forensic scientist who talks
to ghosts."
Ella first mentioned that book in Season 3
"I'm actually writing my own book about a
forensic scientist who talks to ghosts."
and it's based on her own friendship since
she was a child with a ghost named Rae-Rae.
Continuing the ghostly theme, in another episode,
Ella wears a T-shirt with the pun Holy Sheet
on it that features a ghost wearing a halo,
which is perfect because that ghost Ella believes
she met as a kid is actually a holy being:
Lucifer's sister, Azrael!
In episode 11, as a doctor gets ready to perform
her latest surgery, she says:
It's a beautiful day to operate.
Which is a play on the line "It's a beautiful
day to save lives" from the long-running medical
drama Grey's Anatomy.
When Lucifer arrives at an aquarium where
a body's been dumped in the shark tank, the
first thing he says is:
"Sharks, one of Earth's most misunderstood
creatures.
Definitely correcting that when I'm God."
Which is a throw-back to Season 3 where he
decided there were better ways to spend his
time than trying to kill Pierce, aka Cain:
"There are far better ways to spend my time."
"Oh?"
"Take a nude painting class.
Buy that pet shark I've always wanted."
The number on the ticket Luci gets when he
leaves his car with a valet is 666, the number
of the beast in the Book of Revelation and
widely associated with the Antichrist or devil.
This isn't the first time that number's appeared,
for example, it was also tattooed on Lucifer's
torso.
And when Luci appeared during an Arrowverse
crossover event, we learnt that he lives on
Earth-666.
When God pops up at a crime scene and tells
Chloe he's made himself human, Lucifer makes
a joke of it:
"Oh, he does inexplicable things from time
to time.
Marsupials, pomegranates, the gall bladder."
As throwaway as that gag is, the mention of
pomegranates caught my attention as they've
appeared on the show before, with several
paintings of them in the law office of Charlotte
the Goddess.
Which is fitting as some scholars believe
that pomegranates, not apples, were the fruit
that tempted Adam and Eve in the Garden of
Eden.
When Chloe asks a medium where she was during
a murder, she replies:
"Giving a reading...
to a programming exec...
at Fox."
"Oh, good luck with that."
Lucifer's comment is a hilarious burn on the
show's previous home Fox which cancelled the
series after its third season, following which
an online campaign by Lucifans saw it picked
up by Netflix.
As Amenadiel excitedly reveals he wants to
join the police and would love to work with
Dan one day, his friend's response isn't anywhere
near as supportive as he'd hoped:
"Yeah, an angel and a detective solving crimes,
makes total sense."
Of course, we love meta-moments like this
one in the series, which basically sums up
the premise of the show, and is a spin on
Luci's song:
"Crime-solving Devil.
It makes sense.
Don't over think it."
During Lucifer's mission to find out which
of his siblings will help him rather than
Michael become God, he says to his brother
Jophiel:
"I'm assuming you're Team Lucifer"
Which is a call-back to the Season 1 episode
#TeamLucifer where corrupt cop Malcolm told
Amenadiel he wasn't going to help him kill
Luci anymore:
"Unless you got a better offer...
#TeamLucifer."
Also, I love the writers' sense of humour
in making Jophiel a huge himbo as, according
to Wikipedia, not only does his name mean
"divine beauty" but he's also supposed to
be an "archangel of wisdom, understanding,
and judgment".
The day Season 5A dropped on Netflix, Tom
Ellis was straight on social media tweeting
#michaelisadick.
And a shout-out to that trending topic made
it into Season 5B when Jophiel and Lucifer
discuss Michael's nefarious ways:
"Whispering in Dad's ear, making him think
he was losing his powers in the first place,
all so he could take over now."
"Yeah, Michael's kind of a dick."
He's a massive dick.
At the start of the season finale, Michael
plays an off-key version of the popular jazz
song Heart And Soul, which is often performed
as a piano duet, as it was by Chloe and Lucifer
in Season 1.
Michael's out-of-tune performance and the
fact he plays by himself fits perfectly with
his whole character and emphasises how totally
at odds he is in everything with his musical
and sociable twin brother.
Also, intriguingly, two of the times this
particular song has popped up in the series,
it's happened shortly before a reveal that
one of Luci's brothers has got their hands
on a weapon that could have dire consequences
for the devil and even the world.
In season 1, it was an untraceable gun that
Amenadiel wanted Malcolm to kill Lucifer with.
While in season 5B, it's the Flaming Sword,
which Michael claims to have, though he's
lying at that point, and which he intends
to use to beat Lucifer in the latest Celestial
battle.
When God and the Goddess finally exit this
world to live together in her universe, they
do so at Lucifer's club, pulling aside the
curtains and walking out into the light.
All of which happens, appropriately enough,
right underneath the sign LUX, the Latin word
for light!
Lucifer decides to pick up a new instrument
this season:
"I think I'm going to learn the French horn."
Which is a fun hat-tip to Tom Ellis's own
life as he actually learned to play the French
horn at the age of 8 or 9 and played in orchestras,
including the City of Sheffield Youth Orchestra,
throughout his teenage years.
"My French horn.
Just on my way to chuck it out."
While Eve waits for her date to turn up at
the bar, she drinks an appletini, the same
tipple she ordered when she first appeared
in Season 4,
though this time it comes complete with a
slice of apple, all of which is a nice nod
to Eve's backstory with what's often thought
to be the Garden of Eden's forbidden fruit.
Just when Michael thinks Lucifer has accepted
him as the new God,
"You ready to bend the knee, brother?"
his devilish twin pulls a fast one:
"You are God...
awful!
What on earth are you wearing?
Is winter coming or something?"
But Lucifer trash-talking his brother's Game
of Thrones-style garb isn't the first time
he's used the hit show's famous phrase.
Back when Chloe was worried about Father Kinley's
prophecy, Luci asked her:
"What is it this time?
Perhaps winter is coming."
And, I'm not sure if it's intended but, at
the family dinner, when Lucifer noisily drags
his chair to the head of the table, I couldn't
help but think of a certain Thrones character
who also had a rather difficult relationship
with his family.
When Chloe reunites with her dad in Heaven,
they enjoy a picnic together and, in a lovely
throwback to season 2, the traditional Decker
family egg sandwiches are on the menu:
"Egg sandwiches.
A Decker family tradition."
[Chloe] So good.
"Grandpa used to bring me this sandwich every
Thursday after acting class."
"So good."
By the way, the actor who plays Chloe's father
here is Chris Payne Gilbert, real-life husband
of Maze actress Lesley-Ann Brandt.
Lucifer is met in Heaven by Lee, aka Mr Said-Out
Bitch, who's been a regular in the show's
season premieres over the years.
And when Luci says he's been saved by Lilith's
immortality ring, Lee's reply:
"I don't know what the fork any of that means."
is a tribute to the brilliant TV comedy The
Good Place set in the afterlife where curse
words are censored in hilarious ways.
"Somebody royally forked up.
Why can't I say 'fork'?"
Maze breaks down when she finds an old T-shirt
Dan had to pinch after she knocked him out
and left him naked in Chloe's bed back in
Season 1.
That NSYNC T-shirt, which originally belonged
to Chloe, reflects her love of 90s music,
something Lucifer has ribbed her about over
the years:
"Full of '90s jams, I see.
The Bangles, NSync, Right Said Fred?"
And I go into full detail on the masses of
easter eggs and references in the Daniel Espinoza:
Naked and Afraid episode in my next video.
"Countless hours of meticulous planning, dozens
of favors called in."
So, tap here or click the link in the description
below for that video as soon as it's ready.
Now, what were your favourite moments in the
second part of Season 5?
And did you spot any other easter eggs or
cool details?
Leave your thoughts in the comments below.
Tap left to watch my full Lucifer playlist
including part 2 ending explained and season
6 theories.
Or tap right for another video you're sure
to like.
And if you enjoyed this, a thumbs-up and a
share are hugely appreciated.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!